[Música]
me gusta estar con ustedes hoy
han hablado de temas tan diversos y
escuchado tantas historias hoy que me
siento bastante inspirado para contarles
un poquito de la mía
como ven la verdad vengo un lugar bien
caluroso soy de culiacán y cuando yo
está chiquito teníamos un árbol de
mangos en nuestro patio que siempre que
queríamos se llenaba de varios de varios
frutos
saben cuánto tiempo tarda en crecer un
mango
nosotros veíamos a lo largo del año
pequeñas bolitas que se iban haciendo en
las ramas que pusieron árbol lotes nos
ponían a recoger todas las hojas en el
verano que se cayó en el trabajo
monumental y vemos cómo cambiaban de un
verde a un amarillo a un rojo intenso
que decía que están maduras más o menos
por ahí del mes de junio
no saben lo que el recuerdo me causa
bastante delicia son cosas increíbles
para que uno de estos árboles empiece a
dar su primer fruto tienen que haber
pasado al menos siete años
cada uno de esos mangos crece en el
árbol durante cuatro meses antes de que
lo puedan cosechar
en el campo ese mango se cosecha a mano
la cáscara es tan blanda que si se daña
se vuelve un producto de segunda y al
productor ya no le conviene venderlo
entonces nomás lo tira
se estima que entre un 30 y un 40% de
esta producción
se deshace todos los años
si le sumamos que al mango solamente
comemos la pulpa que es entre un 40 y un
60% dependiendo de la variedad
estamos tirando más del 60% de lo que
cosechamos de mango cada año es una
locura es demasiado somos 8000 millones
de personas en el mundo y cada día se
está volviendo más difícil poder nos
alimentar a todos
según la onu
para que exista seguridad alimentaria
tenemos que tener en todo momento acceso
tanto físico como económico alimentos
que sean nutritivos e inocuos que nos
vamos comer
esto para tener una vida sana lo que a
mí me preocupa es que todo este
desperdicio no nos damos cuenta y no les
buscamos un valor agregado a tanta cosa
que ya estamos produciendo
buscar maneras de generar oferta
alimentaria hay muchas la que es para mí
más lógica es poder trabajar en esta
cadena de productos esta cadena
alimentaria donde ya tenemos muchos
recursos
según la fao un tercio de lo que
producimos
lo desperdiciamos en américa latina
ese número es 34% y afecta más que nada
a frutas y hortalizas como el mango de
ese 34
13% se desperdicia de la semilla al
fruto
además el 8 por ciento una vez que lo
cosechamos 5 por ciento en lo que lo
procesamos y lo envasamos 4 por ciento
en la distribución y 4 por ciento en lo
que consumimos diariamente
es una locura que al principio de la
cadena tengamos tanto que se está
desperdiciando
se estima que son 223 kilos por cada uno
de nosotros en el mundo al año que se
están yendo a la basura
que es suficiente para poder alimentar a
300 millones de personas
no sé ustedes pero a mí realmente esto
me empezó a cambiar las ideas y fue
entonces cuando decidí generar alguna
alternativa alguna propuesta que pudiera
cambiar este número
yo soy de las personas que piensa que
esto es como un círculo la vida en sí
nos va a regresar las razones y nos va a
decir que las cosas pasaron por algo
yo siempre quise haber sido chef me
encanta la comida me ama me regañaba
porque la seguía por la cocina todos los
días y empecé a agarrar todo lo que
dejaba ahí en la mesa y hacia mis
menjurjes mis experimentos yo llegué a
la preparatoria con toda la intención de
hacerme un restaurantero un chef y
puedes llevar las delicias gastronómicas
que más quieran
pero la situación de la noche de la
mañana en mi casa cambió y no teníamos
realmente el recurso económico para
poder hacer algo de esta magnitud es
alguna carrera bastante cara y lo que
hice fue buscar una beca pero en contra
en ingenierías realmente no puede
mostrar mis habilidad culinarios para ir
por los números hice una que otra cosa y
estoy en biotecnología del tec
pero siempre espere en que el mundo de
los alimentos me llamara de vuelta para
poder hacer lo que realmente me apasiona
este problema de una falta de alimentos
para todos aunque los tengamos por ahí
fue lo que me regreso a buscar mi pasión
hablando de eso regresemos al mango un
poquito qué pasaría si aprovecháramos el
100% de ese mango que estamos tirando si
cada fibra cada proteína cada vitamina
caminera los ató los nutrientes lo
esperamos reintegrar dentro de los
productos que ya consumimos
porque no cambiamos la mentalidad
a mejorar los productos que ya estamos
comprando en el supermercado
volviendo al punto todas esas cosechas
tienen mucho más de dar de sí mismas si
nos enfocamos en entender sus secretos y
en buscar propuestas de valor agregado
al respecto
así es como podemos lograr seguridad
alimentaria
cuatro de cada cinco personas en américa
latina viven en ciudades lo vimos en la
mañana realmente todos estamos
acostumbrados a vivir en ciudades en
méxico este número es 78% para el 2025
un 90 por ciento de la población va a
vivir en ciudades en especial la gente
más bajos recursos
y nosotros que vivimos en estas ciudades
sabemos lo rápido que se mueven las
cosas que buscamos soluciones que sean
prácticas que sean rápidas que sean
accesibles
y que por lo tanto nuestra dieta está
desbalanceada finalmente tenemos
productos a la mano que obtiene no mucho
azúcar o mucha grasa o realmente tienen
calorías vacías y nos hace falta otra
parte de fibras proteínas y otros
nutrientes para poder estar en el
contener en el punto de nutrición que
realmente merecemos
méxico 65% de la población sufre
obesidad y sobrepeso
28 por ciento de obesidad
37% de sobrepeso
somos el segundo país con mayor índice
de obesidad en el mundo
por otro lado ya lo vieron afuera
tenemos las delicias gastronómicas del
mundo y la unesco en el 2014 nombrar la
comida mexicana como patrimonio mundial
de la humanidad
nuestra cultura es mucho nuestra comida
es muy difícil separar al mexicano de lo
que come
entonces por qué no regresarla al
mexicano la nutrición a través de eso
que ya está agarrando
hace 5 años conocí a una persona que
trae esta misma ideología y los dos nos
pusimos a pensar si es tan lógico porque
no se está haciendo y empezamos a ver
ese rompecabezas estado totalmente
fragmentado y desarmado de quién tiene
las cosas a dónde se van dónde se tiran
qué es lo que está realmente pasando en
este mundo de alimentos y aunque el reto
era grande nuestra misión era simple
vamos a hacer de los alimentos
sustentables accesibles y nutritivos
para todos
con esto quiero decir que el pan que te
compras en la tiendita la tortilla con
la que está hasta que 'no más tarde o
más temprano si te fuiste por otros
tacos la salchicha de un hot dog o hasta
al aire eso que le pasas pone a las
papas no solamente te aporte placer sino
también nutrición a un bajo costo suena
bien no
y así es como empecé a trabajar en esto
con una misión local con muchas muchas
ganas pero sin un céntimo empezamos de
la nada
y que fue lo primero que hice que tengo
a mi alrededor
me regresa a mi niñez y esa cocina me
llamó se volvió mi campo de batalla
empecé a experimentar con lo que me
estaba encontrando poco a poco se me fue
siendo más chica más chica más chica y
agarré la lavandería que estaba al lado
hay que mudarnos un poquito al lado
con eso empezamos a buscar quién tenía
todos estos recursos fuimos con el
taquero de la esquina que al final del
día tenía huesos de aguacate a tirar
fuimos con el jugo que estaba a tres
cuadras y agarramos costales de cáscaras
de naranja para ver que podíamos
sacarles de provecho y mi favorito
fuimos con un pulpero que encontramos
por alguna extraña razón agarrar mango
semillas y cáscaras no se imaginan
estarse comiendo un ano pero nosotros en
un principio tampoco y lo que hicimos
fue empezar a generar tecnología a
partir de mexicana das realmente con
toda cualquier cosa que pudiéramos
encontrar para avanzar para adelante
y funciona digo no sin antes 2000
prototipos como un pan que rojo que
teníamos por ahí que nadie se puede
comer que venía de la semilla aguacate
porque estaba nutritivo pero estrella lo
suyo era su bomba
empezamos a generar tecnología que nos
permite hoy en día extraer nutrientes de
todos estos subproductos o residuos como
lo quieran ver
hacerlo es un polvo y que sepan meter en
cualquier receta de los productores
piénsenlo así yo le doy una herramienta
un ingrediente al que hace el pan al que
hace los embutidos para que el género un
mejor producto para ti más nutritivo y a
mejor costo para él
eliminando dos grandes problemas que
estábamos viendo
que es que estamos creando demasiado y
que la nutrición está desbalanceada pero
no pasó de la noche a la mañana
empezamos a juntarnos con ellos a
realmente entender sus necesidades y
vimos que la industria sigue siendo una
industria tiene que generar rentabilidad
no nomás nutrición y buen sabor entonces
empezamos a cambiar nuestro discurso
a alinearlo a sus incentivos a no
dejarnos caer por el status quo que
ellos estaban teniendo es saber hacer
todo sin querer cambiar nada
han sido cinco años de remar
contracorriente en un mundo de alimentos
increíble pero con sus mil vicios pero
eso está cambiando los consumidores cada
día están teniendo mucho más énfasis en
que se hace cómo se hace y qué es lo que
tiene con solo ver cambios de ahora
proteína vegetal en lugar de proteína
animal en muchas cosas de buscar que los
granos antiguos empiecen a entrar en
todas las recetas que tenemos como la
chía cómo
hay varios portales la que se me viene a
la mente
en general la tecnología nos ha
permitido agarrar atrás información ese
rompecabezas y unirlo
y gracias a eso es que estamos avanzando
entonces quiero que se quede en la mente
con ese árbol de mango en mi casa o de
la suya si quieren
debemos empezar a luchar como ese árbol
para agarrar todos los recursos que
tenemos en nuestro a nuestro alcance
quiero que luchemos como ese árbol para
como él lucha contra sus enfermedades
nosotros contra la diabetes la
hipertensión y demás efectos provocados
por la desnutrición
quiero que como ese árbol trabajemos en
conjunto con todo lo que tenemos a un
lado y como ese árbol quiero que lo
hagamos un mango a la vez muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]